- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools, and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got there. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Mark] I would like to thank the
organizers. This is great opportunity to
come and listen to all these talks and
present some as well. So I would like to
start...so genes are really central and
they're central for a couple of reasons.
Well we can use lots of sources of
evidence to identify which are the genes
that are important in any process. Here,
we're talking about skin pigmentation so
we have molecular biology data, clinically
significant conditions generally
hypopigmentation, different types of
albinism, non-human animals especially the
mouse has really been influential in
helping us understand how genes affect
pigmentation. We can follow evolution in a
number of ways; molecular evolution as
well as just the evolution across
different populations. And finally,
Admixture mapping. This is an approach to
find the genes that determine differences
between populations. When we have those
genes, we can then use them to design more
experiments to help us understand better
how they function. So knowing those genes
is really central. We can address
questions like where and when these new
gene mutations happen that give us
different skin color in this case,
potentially improved diagnostic and
treatments, test different kinds of
molecular hypotheses and finally predict
trait values. This could be useful in a
forensic context when the person's not
there, you don't have any information
about who he is, to make some predictions
as well as in Epidemiology. Skin is
mediating something about the disease
condition. We know it's really critical in
producing enough Vitamin D.
We can measure the skin from the DNA
alone, so not having measured it in the
person. So there's a lot of potential
there. Here's an example of a melanocyte
and keratinocytes, typically they reach up
to 30 or 40 keratinocytes and pass off
melanosomes. So it's just a little bit
about the biology. We know a lot about the
genes that are forming these melanosomes
and controlling their transfer up to the
keratinocytes. I've always been fascinated
by human variation and here's a slide of
18 young women who we collected recently
as part of our sampling. You can get
quickly a sense of the diversity of human
pigmentation; skin, hair, and eyes from
this. We can look at more detailed
descriptions, quantitative descriptions.
This is a histogram showing the
pigmentation levels measured in three
populations. The one on the far left is
European-American sample from State
College, the black bars to the right are
African-Americans from Washington DC, and
then a sample of African-Caribbeans from
England. The African-Caribbeans are
shifted over to the right a little bit
compared to the African-Americans and
that's darker skin. In fact they have less
European ancestry, less European admixture
than the African-Americans do; about 10%
compared to 20%. So there's a strong
relationship there between your recent
admixture and your skin color. We do see
too, this red bar here shows the extent of
overlap because this slide also emphasizes
how our observation of each other is
substantially biased.
Sociologists have studied this in detail
and light skinned people see dark skin
people as darker than they are. Dark
skinned people see light skinned people as
lighter than they are. So you can't really
rely on your perceptions or at least it's
worth looking inward to see what effect
that may have on how you see those around
you. We know the environment has been a
major factor in the evolution of skin
color. That green line there is the
equator and latitude or the distance north
and south of the equator have a major
effect on skin color. We know from more
detailed analyses that it's actually the
ultraviolet radiation at ground level that
really has the strongest effect on skin
color. So our skin is tied to the
environment and we can propose or discuss
the different mechanisms that may be
controlling this response. I think the
strongest evidence is for lightning of
skin due to the need to produce Vitamin D.
A very few natural sources that we can
dietarily consume enough Vitamin D to keep
us healthy, but our skin can produce
Vitamin D. So with ultraviolet light
hitting your skin, you can produce Vitamin
D if your skin's light enough for that
environment and if you're exposed enough,
if you have enough skin showing and if you
spend enough time outdoors. So lots of
conditions on being healthy through
getting your Vitamin D from your skin.
Potentially immune suppression is also
something that is good in certain
instances. Darker skin probably evolved to
protect us from sunburn, skin cancer,
protect us from too much immune
suppression and also perhaps to mediate
folic acid photolysis to protect our folic
acid stores from being destroyed.
Ultraviolet light helps to create Vitamin
D, but it also destroys folic acid.
Finally, both low and high pigmentation
can be mediated through sexual selection
and also the relaxation of selection as
population move from one area to another
area. We can talk about the average
history of individuals, persons and
populations. And this tree shows... I know
it's kind of complex but that's really the
best representation that we can make of
our history. Although this is about 10
years old, I think it still holds in most
of the major branches here. And it's not
only a branching through the fission,
separation of populations, but also the
fusion of populations. You can see here
how we have drawn these little branches
here to illustrate admixture or the
movement of people to join other
populations. Our species really has much
more of a wisteria vine history when
branches cross they fuse and they join
again making new populations as opposed to
any kind of tree or bush pattern. That is
an average pattern. Evolution really
doesn't happen...at least a lot of
evolution, the adaptive evolution, happens
more on a gene by gene basis. So it's
modular, each gene has its own history.
The genes that cause differences among us
today are genes that have very recent
evolutionary histories and have been very
actively evolving in the past 75,000
years, say, since human populations had
their common origin in Africa. Many
populations stayed in Africa, some small
set of populations moved out of Africa.
We have tools that let us study how
these...tracking the molecular evolution
of these genes and how quickly they
evolved showing clear evidence that they
have evolved recently or changed frequency
recently. So these are very valuable
tools. I'll show you an application of one
of those methods in a minute. But I want
to focus really on just three populations
to start with. These aren't the three most
important populations or three central
populations. That tree I showed you before
is really a better sampling of human
diversity, but these are worth looking at.
We were initially very light skinned
before we lost our fur, all mammals are.
You spread your cat's fur, even if it's a
black cat, you'll see the skin is white
underneath. As we lost our fur, changed
our habits, we needed to become dark
skinned. There's other branches here, the
second branch is a common branch to East
Asians and Europeans. The third branch
there would contain skin lightening events
that were specific to East Asians, the
fourth branch is the branch specific to
European changes. Finally, additional skin
darkening events possibly on that fifth
branch that I show in this tree. So I
mentioned admixture mapping before and
this is really a fundamental tool for
finding genes that cause differences
between populations. Most of the genes are
the same across all populations. If you
look at the frequencies of alleles across
populations, about 95% of the total
variation is in common. We have this very
recent common history, but for certain
things, especially superficial aspects,
superficial traits, we have evolved very
quickly and we can map those kinds of
genes with this approach. So we basically
start out with two parents; one light skin
and one dark skin. These are the
histograms describing their distributions.
When they mate, you have the first admixed
generation and there is much less
variation in skin color here or whatever
trait it is that you're talking about.
Everybody has two copies, two genomes; one
from European ancestor and one from an
African ancestor in this case. But by the
second generation and all the generations
afterwards, you have a lot of variation. A
lot of phenotypic variation and these are
ideal samples for discovering which are
the genes that are affecting this trait.
Here it is as a chromosomal view. So you
have two European chromosomes, two African
chromosomes or one of each. You get one of
each by having one parent from each
population. These black bars are
recombination points so you don't pass on
to your kids the same chromosomes you got
from your parents. You mix them up and
then pass on this mixed up set of
chromosomes to your kids. And after a few
generations, you end up with these
chimeric chromosomes that have different
ancestry segments. We can track those
ancestry segments and use that information
to map genes. We do need to be careful
about stratification. So there's variation
in admixture levels across population.
This slide here shows you how the
proportion of West African ancestry is
positively correlated with the skin color
measure, the M index. You see a positive
correlation, you also see the variance is
different so there is a lot more
dispersion here, a lot more variability.
This is because like most traits, skin
color is much more variable in Africa.
Even just considering the subset of
Africa, West Africa where the enslaved
ancestors of the African-Americans and
Brazilians and other populations that are
represented here were derived. So even at
that subset of Africa is much more
variable than Europe.
But you have this confounding. So you have
to deal with the fact that ancestry is
going to be correlated with any...our skin
color will be correlated with any marker
that you measure that's different between
those parental groups. But you can reduce
that, you can remove that statistically.
It's a process called conditioning or
controlling. You basically remove the
effects of one variable to study another.
This is the Duffy null locus, locus of
very substantially between populations and
you can see the genotype determines the
distribution of skin color. It has nothing
to do with skin color. When you control
for the variation and ancestry, you get
rid of that effect on skin color. This is
the cover of the journal where we
published on the SLC24A5 gene. This gene
was first discovered by Keith Cheng as the
golden gene for zebra fish. So it affected
zebra fish coloration. Keith called me up
and said, "Hey, maybe this affects skin
color." I was quite skeptical until I
looked at public data set where it showed
a locus where Europeans, the blue dot
here, were totally fixed for an allele.
You didn't find much in other populations.
That's a very unusual circumstance and
sure enough it has a very dramatic effect
on skin color. You can see that here even
after controlling for ancestry, you still
have a strong effect on skin color. And in
fact in genome-wide admixture mapping we
find SLC24A5 is really the strongest gene
affecting skin color. You see these other
smaller peaks here. Once you condition for
the effect of SLC24A5, those genes are
much more prominent. So you can see that
you can detect those. So this statistical
conditioning is a very common tool and
very useful.
One of the interesting things we found
about not only SLC24A5 but some of those
other genes that come up in this gene
mapping analysis like SLC45A2 or the MATP
gene is that the variation that causes
Europeans to be light skinned is not the
same as the variation that causes East
Asians to be light skinned. So this
selective pressure to lighten the skin
probably in response to migrating to
higher latitudes where there's less UV
light was quite strong. I mean it seems to
affect any population that moves to a
higher latitude. This is really kind of
unexpected. We had other hypotheses about
populations like Melanesians maybe they
shared or didn't share genes with darker
skinned populations, but this is what we
found. And in fact, there are many genes,
I'm not going to talk to you about many of
these other genes, but I just wanted to
show you a slide that identified what
we're finding about where these genes
occur and on which branches they seem to
have evolved. So we're not finding too
many that are on this common branch of
lightning, in the common population coming
out of Africa and only a few that are back
as far as on the common branch of all
human populations. But some of these are
more difficult to study, too. This is
probably the case. I don't think that
those genes don't exist and we can't
understand them, we just haven't been able
to find them yet. One very interesting
tool we have is to look at the local
genetic diversity. So this is using Short
Tandem Repeats or STRs. If you watch too
many crime TV shows, you probably already
know this acronym.
But these are the markers you use for
identity analysis if you have a forensic
case you type the STR alleles. You can see
there's lots of different variants. This
is the chromosome here that doesn't have
the new allele, the A allele, that gives
you a lighter skin. This is the chromosome
with the lighter skin. So you can see
there is much less variation on that
chromosome even though it's basically
fixed in Europeans. So there's lots of
copies of that chromosome which usually
means it's old and you are going to see
lots of different mutations on it. Lots of
different STR alleles, but you don't. You
only see pretty much one primary alleles
on most of these. So you can use that
information to date when that mutation
occurred or when it started to change
frequency. That's really the more
important point is when did that really
start to evolve. So the dates or the time
is here and the selective coefficient, how
strong the selection was is there, and you
can put these on a tree then. So you can
look at when the timing of some of these
genes SLC24A5, MATP, and TRP1 changed
frequency compared to when KIT Ligand and
some of the other ones changed frequency.
And they seem to match those splits on the
tree. So I just want to say we're very
grateful to all of our volunteers who
participated in these research projects
and I have lots of other colleagues who
have also helped in getting to this point
and then several other research labs as
well who are looking into a lot of these
same questions. Thank you very much.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Nina] We share with these beautiful
cousins of ours skin that serves a variety
of important functions, and we've heard a
lot about those functions already today:
protection, thermoregulation. Today, I'm
going to reprise a little bit of what's
been said already about the first two
functions, and then talk somewhat about
this enormous realm of human communication
that we engage in with skin. Over time,
and through evolution, if we compare the
relative importance of protection and
thermoregulation versus communication, we
can see that in human evolution,
communication has become one of the major
functions of skin especially since the
evolution of functionally naked skin. I
want to first just reprise a little bit
information about protection, though,
because it's useful to think about what we
lost. Hair is enormously useful, and our
primate relatives and our mammalian
ancestors had hair that help to insulate
and protect against all manner of
environmental problems and abrasion,
ultraviolet radiation and water, and hair
helps to slow the ingress of pathogens to
the skin. But we lost hair, and although
there is some controversy about why we
lost it and exactly when, we know that we
now have functionally naked skin probably
by early Homo times, and almost certainly
for reasons having to do with the need to
keep cool during exercise by a high volume
of eccrine sweating. And what the
important conclusion of this is is that
for much of our...the key portions of our
evolution, hairless bodies are interfaced
with the environment.
A very different situation than in other
mammals. The evolution of the stratum
corneum, the very top part of the
epidermis is something that has been dealt
with a lot in the dermatological
literature. We know that the epidermis,
and particularly the stratum corneum at
the very surface of the epidermis, here,
resists abrasion, restricts water loss,
and prevents the ingress of pathogens. But
that great change from the haired to the
hairless condition basically involved
changes to the stratum corneum. So when we
think about really what Ajit Varki's point
was at the very beginning of this
symposium, "Why is the skin different." We
see from referring to the chimp genome
project that in fact, the skin is the most
distinct organ. Human skin has been...has
many genes that have been evolving
independently, and very different from
those of chimpanzees much more so than any
organ or cell system. And the most
important genes in this regard are those
having to do with the stratum corneum and
the barrier functions of the epidermis. We
could go on at length, my colleague, Peter
Elias has done distinguished work in this
area. We know that this stratum corneum in
humans is particularly lipid-rich that we
have interferon gamma that helps to
generate a potent antiviral state in the
stratum corneum and that the skin
microbiome plays an enormously important
and still quite unclear, but emerging
role.
The skin also has to protect against
another major assault which is that of the
sun and particularly, ultraviolet
radiation. We know from data provided from
NASA that the ultraviolet radiation load
that we get on the Earth's surface is
strongest around the equator shown in the
bright pink and red tones here in the map.
Much, much lower as we get close to the
poles, especially in these large land
masses in the northern hemisphere. How
have humans coped with these high levels
of UV in our ancestral areas, and much
lower levels in areas of habitation later
in aspects of our evolution? In early
Homo, the loss of body hair is associated
with the development of permanent, dark
pigmentation. So instead of having dark
hair covering lightly pigmented skin, we
evolve permanently, darkly pigmented skin.
And that is largely to do with the
production of high amounts of the
tremendously interesting pigment called
eumelanin; a fascinating polymer that has
myriad important properties. The most
important for our purposes being the
ability to scatter and absorb ultraviolet
radiation and prevent damage to underlying
tissues. Ultraviolet radiation causes a
lot of damage to the skin that can lead to
skin cancer, especially in individuals who
are genetically susceptible. But skin
cancer rarely causes mortality.
So I, as someone who is interested in
figuring out why skin pigmentation evolved
as it did, and specifically why dark
pigmentation evolved, got very interested
in the effect of ultraviolet radiation on
something that would really count for
reproductive success in evolution. And I
started looking a lot at folate
metabolism. Without going into a lot
detail, suffice it to say that we need
folate, one of the key B vitamins, in
order to fuel DNA synthesis which is
particularly important in certain parts of
our development in life especially in
early embryogenesis. When we know that
folate is critical for the formation of
the embryonic neural tube which is the
precursor of the modern, or the adult,
nervous system. So, if you have an
environmental agent like ultraviolet
radiation that can actually break down
folate and affect other aspects of folate
metabolism in a pregnant mother, then you
can affect reproductive success, and this
is why we've highlighted that mechanism.
So.here I say the primary, not the only,
but the primary selective force for the
evolution of permanent dark pigmentation
is protection against ultraviolet-induced
changes in folate availability and DNA
synthesis in early embryogenesis and in
sperm production. But humans did not
remain in the ancestral environment of
Africa. Much of human evolution, including
much of Homo Sapien's evolution, has
occurred in Africa. Tremendous amounts of
diversification, but humans have moved
around a lot.
And here we can see in the history of
modern humans. We have people
moving...small populations moving out of
Africa into areas of very different
ultraviolet radiation including very low
areas or very low UV areas later in our
evolutionary history. Why is that
important? Because ultraviolet radiation,
mostly a malign influence that we think
about in evolution, is a creative
influence, and is extremely important in
all vertebrates in the production of
Vitamin D in the skin. Without
ultraviolet-B radiation we cannot make
Vitamin D in the skin. And what we have
shown in our research and this has been
supported by many collateral lines of
evidence is that the primary selective
force for the evolution of lightly pink
bennet [SP] or more correctly, depigmented
skin is promotion of ultraviolet
radiation-induced Vitamin D production in
the skin under conditions of low and
seasonal ultraviolet radiation. And so
here in modern humans, we have this
beautiful and delightful contrast between
skin on the left that maximizes photo
protection against ultraviolet radiation,
and skin on the right that maximizes
photosynthesis of Vitamin D under
conditions of low UV. Skin pigmentation is
a superb evolutionary compromise.
Something that we should talk about in our
classes of evolution and human biology; a
superb compromise that is an excellent
illustration of the action of natural
selection on the human body.
Themoregulation, I'm only going to say
that as we evolved through time, we became
far more active. This beautiful example of
an early member of the genus Homo was not
a tentative biped. This was a striding,
running, active individual that built up a
lot of body heat under hot environmental
conditions. Here was the natural selective
substrate, as it were, for the loss of
most functional body hair. Evaporation of
sweat is impeded by hair, and so we
reasoned that most body...most functional
body hair was actually lost because of the
importance of facilitating the evaporation
of sweat from the surface of the body. And
so, functional hairlessness, then, can
best be thought about as facilitating
active body cooling, whole body cooling,
through eccrine sweating during lengthy
periods of sustained exercise.
Communication has always been an important
function of skin, whether we're talking
about a distant mammalian ancestor or a
primate relative. Primates touch one
another. Communication through touch
especially beginning with infant-mother
communication is central. This continues,
and is elaborated in the hairless human
infant and in hairless bodies contacting
one another. And we know that this type of
touch communication is absolutely
essential for mother-infant bonding in our
primate relatives and in ourselves. When
we lost most of our body hair, we lost an
important method of displaying our
emotions. This chimpanzee on the left is
exhibiting a display, a very visible
display, of anger and aggression toward
the individual on the right.
And he is able to manifest this
magnificent raising of hackles. What do we
do without hair? We have no hackles. We
might...our little feeble hairs might go
up. What do we do instead? We don't know
for certain, but what we do know is that
modern humans have much more finely
differentiated, and highly active facial
muscles than do even chimpanzees, and we
have the evolution of enhanced facial
expressivity in humans that is probably
related to that loss of expressivity in
the raising of the hackles. As soon as
humans evolved naked skin or probably very
soon, thereafter, people realized that
they could decorate their skin. We don't
know when they happened upon this, but we
have some enticing evidence that comes
from Blombos Cave in South Africa from
about 70,000 years ago that would indicate
that by that time, people were beginning
to use ocher for decorations and for
decorating the inside of rock shelters.
This is exciting because I would venture
that probably long before this, humans had
been using ocher and similar pigments to
rub on themselves, to mark themselves. We
can't prove this, but it seems highly
likely. Humans are lavish decorators of
themselves. We may not have colorful fur,
but we more than compensate for this by
having myriad ways of decorating ourselves
with body paint, with cosmetics.
In most cultures, both sexes are involved
and many parts of the body are involved in
decoration. There is no culture that we
know in the world that does not adorn its
skin in some way. Modern humans have
developed not only body paints but also
cosmetics. Now, mostly associated with
women, but certainly centuries ago, not. A
lavish form of communication that is
incredibly important that individuals can
manipulate and change from one day or one
season to another. We also start making
permanent marks on our body. We know from
the preserved remains of the so-called
Tyrolean iceman, dating from around 5,000
years ago, that we have evidence of
tattooing of the skin. These are thought
to be therapeutic tattoos that were on the
skin not necessarily decorative. Many of
them are crosses or simple lines, parallel
lines. But the fact that they are present
that early in the archaeological record in
neolithic humans is significant. And
humans around the world tattoo themselves,
and sometimes lavishly. This woman from
Burma has beautiful facial tattoos that
signify her marriageable status. And that
identify her to a particular clan group.
But what do we say just through our color?
And the rest of this lecture I want to
devote to the messages, the communication
that actually comes from our color.
During most of human history, humans moved
around slowly. They came into contact with
one another gradually. There were no big
surprises. And it's not surprising that
through much of history, not just
prehistory but much of history, we have no
indication that humans treated one another
differently on the basis of color. It only
is relatively recent, in the last few
hundred years that color becomes something
that has social significance, and that has
some kind of set of stereotypes and even
stigmas attached to it. We really see the
emergence of a modern color-consciousness
beginning in the 18th century when innate
skin color comes to communicate both
racial identity or race belonging, and
social status. One of the most interesting
figures in this history is the philosopher
Immanuel Kant. Immanuel Kant was a very
careful reader of Linnaeus, the great
taxonomist. Linnaeus made very simple
descriptions of humans according to skin
color and geography. Later, he associated
skin color and geography with some
characteristics of behavior and culture.
Kant was an avid reader of Linnaeus, and
Kant, although he's known far more for his
thoughts on rationality and human
thinking, had tremendous curiosity about
human diversity, human origins, and the
origins of human capacity for
civilization.
And so, he thought a lot about Linnaeus
and what Linnaeus said, and Kant, not a
naturalist, but Immanuel Kant the
philosopher, was the first to actually
enunciate the presence of four races. And
the key thing about Kant's races where
that in his mind, they were immutable.
They couldn't change ever. And this was
just not a list, it was a hierarchy. And
critical here is the primacy of the white
race which is something that we see
emerging again in different guises for
many centuries, for many decades after
this. Kant's tremendous influence was
complemented by the importance of
maintaining a strict social hierarchy in
order to keep the trans-Atlantic slave
trade going. By the early 1800s, there was
tremendous pressure to end slavery, to end
the slave trade. But it was very, very
financially appealing and important for
the hierarchy of races and especially the
primacy of the white race over the
so-called black race to be enunciated so
that slavery could be maintained. And we
see this complementarity between a
philosophical and a religious or
pseudo-religious underpinning for race
hierarchies and slavery along with the
mercantile and capitalist underpinnings. A
very pernicious system that led to the
social differentiation of color.
Something that hadn't existed at least in
as strong a form and violent a form
before. And so we see race definitions
that are associated with color that lead
seemingly inexorably to the development of
racial stereotypes especially when they're
propagated by individuals like Kant, like
Thomas Jefferson who were highly, socially
influential through their writings leading
to the development of what I've called
color memes that are adopted and
transmitted from family to family,
generation to generation leading to a
durable psychosocial template for racism.
So skin, coming from this delightful and
beautiful evolutionary background, skin
color actually reflects our evolutionary
history, but in this most recent part of
human written history comes to represent
something entirely different. But I am not
a pessimistic person, and the beautiful
thing about humans as primates is that we
are tremendously imitative and suggestible
and we can change. We adopted in Western
civilization broadly, certain attitudes
toward color and we can change those
attitudes. We're not trapped by the color
memes that we have created. And this
aspect of communication through skin can
in fact change. I want to celebrate the
beauty of human skin and invite you to
think more about the exquisite path that
skin has taken through the last seven or
so million years of the human lineage.
The evolution of hairlessness, functional
nakedness, sweating, the development of
these marvelous appendages, and the
beautiful feast of microbes and other
creatures that live on the surface of our
skin. And then, the superb things that we
do with this beautiful, naked canvass that
has been produced by evolution. Let's
celebrate those and continue an active
program of research. Thank you very much.
♪ [music] ♪
- [James] I'd like to thank very much to
the organizers of this conference for
inviting me. I just want to, as I
frequently speak to clinical audiences, I
have to make my declaration of disclaim. I
essentially work in borrowed space, use
borrowed money, and I'm living on borrowed
time. Hence, I like as my theme Thomas
Huxley's remark that, "Scientists over 60
do more harm than good." Now I want to
direct you to a traveling story. Skin is
our major defense against an onslaught of
one of the strongest carcinogens that we
experience, ultraviolet light. And some
years ago I was directed to this village
in Northern Guatemala were the
missionary's orders that the children had
enormous amount of skin cancer, and they
were dying at 10 years of age. Now,
commonly, you would think skin cancer as
an older person's problem. These are
dramatic examples of how, if we lose the
genetic defense against sun exposure,
cancer can be an enormously disastrous
problem at the skin level. So they
directed me to this village and it had the
phenotype of a disease that I'd work for
many years, xeroderma pigmentosum. That's
normally a recessive disease. In then U.
S.population, it occurs about one to four
per million of the population. Twenty-five
percent of the children had this disease.
They lived under extreme poverty. When we
had a look at the patients, you could see
the enormous sun damage of their face, and
the painful sunburns. When we brought
cells back, you can see here and exposed
these cells to ultraviolet in the lab
where the normal skin has excellent
survival, their cells were killed at very,
very low doses of UV.
So they had a genetic predisposition in
which they could not handle sun exposure,
solar exposure. We sequenced, and we found
that they lacked what you call now the
global genome repair pathway. The founder
effect in this village was a mutation
which caused...which removed one cytosine
from a gene we call XPC which is one of
the main damage recognition proteins in
the skin. When we did...even a staining of
a section of the skin, the black staining
here, indications of high expression of
the XPC protein in the epidermis of normal
skin. From the Guatemalan village, there
is no expression of this gene. As a
result, their cells fail to recognize DNA
damage and it goes on to develop into
cancer. I will show you some of the
ramifications of this. Now, xeroderma
pigmentosum, XP, is one of a family of
some sensitive diseases involving
different components of the nucleotide
excision repair pathway. As an aside, I'd
just like to mention that you may have
seen that the Nobel prize for chemistry
this year was given to Tom Lindahl, Z.
Sancar, and the mismatch repair pathway
for unraveling the biochemistry of this
pathway. Now, xeroderma pigmentosum is
unique from among the repair systems for
solar UV in that they have very high
cancer. These other diseases are also
components of the same repair pathway, but
they essentially are photosensitive but
without skin cancer.
And especially a disease here known as the
UVS syndrome has acute sunburn, but no
neurological disorders, none of the
developmental disorders or the current
Cockayne syndrome, and a very mild
version. So there's an extremely wide
variation in the genetic response to sun
exposure. Now the main photoproducts
caused by UV occur between two adjacent
pyrimidines in the DNA. The major
photoproduct is the dimer in which two
covalent bonds are formed. An alternative
photoproduct, the 6-4 photoproduct. Now if
you do not remove these photoproducts,
either of these, if you don't remove them
bio-chemically from the DNA, they can go
on to interfere with DNA replication. And
a cytosine and a TC photoproduct can
deaminate, code as an A, you know, codes
as a T and then opposite an A is placed.
After two cycles of replication, a TC
sequence becomes a TT. So, a C to a T
transition mutation in a TC sequence is an
absolute fingerprint for UV exposure and a
UV-induced mutation. Now, the excision
repair pathway for UV damage has two major
routes. If the DNA is unexpressed, which
is a large majority of our DNA, damage is
recognized by a dedicated damage
recognition protein of which XPC, the
Guatemalan population, has a mutation. So
they failed to recognize. An alternative
mechanism by which damage is recognize is
an arrested transcription. If cells cannot
recover from this, they have the disease
called Cockayne syndrome.
And then, these two pathways converge on
an extensive remodeling system to repair
the DNA. If we look more closely at the
transcription process, there are two
strands, the coding strands and a template
strand. The template strand is the one
which is transcribed into RNA. The repair
of these two strands is different. The XPC
system repairs this strand. The
transcribed strand is repaired by a
complex of proteins that are associated
with a transcription complex. The
difference between these two strands have
a major impact on carcinogenesis. First,
if you look at repair in terms of the
removal of a number of photoproducts, with
time, in a highly expressed gene like P53
or Dhfr, the photoproducts were remove
rapidly. In unexpressed or lower expressed
genes, the photoproducts were removed to a
much lower extent. So the rate of repair
depends upon which strand the damage lies.
We then collaborated recently with a group
in Seattle, Laura Loeb and Kev Bayliss, in
which they use a high throughput
sequencing method to determine exactly
what are the sequence changes in a
UV-rated population. Now, those of
you...those of us who have worked in a
million [sp] cell biology and tissue
culture immunogenesis realize that over
the years, we've only had one or two genes
that are capable of studying mutagenesis
in culture because of the number...the
rarity of having a drug-selectable locus.
With high throughput sequencing, we can
get by that completely. And so, here is
the result of measuring the mutation
frequency in nucleotide changes per 10 to
the 7th nucleotides. High resolution
sequencing averaged over a large number of
genes that are relevant for skin cancer.
And you can see that a wild-type normal
cell has a low increase in mutations or
function of dose, but in a XPC such as we
see in Guatemala village, enormous
increase in mutation rates.
Going up from 0.5 up to 5, a tenfold or
more increase in mutation rates. We then
decided once we had that system working,
we went back to Guatemala and with some
help of a clinical service team that goes
there from San Diego regularly to treat
the patients and give them some clinical
help, we brought back five squamous
carcinomas from this population. Sequenced
three million single nucleotide mutations
by exome sequencing. Transition mutations
were a majority in XPC. Now since it was a
small population size, we didn't
concentrate on which genes were mutated,
but we asked, "What is the frequency of
mutations per kilobase across the whole
genome?" and asked, "What's the mutation
density?" When we do that...this is a very
interesting situation to illustrate how
the genome structure and function have a
major impact on mutation rates. In a
normal population...see in here, normal
squamous carcinomas from a normal
population. There is a protein in the
histone that methylates a region and
suppresses access for other enzymes. As a
result, the mutation density goes up
because those regions of the chromatin are
inaccessible to repair. As transcription
increases across the genome, we find that
this is...removes the repression, and as a
result mutation frequency declines. But
still, if you compare the non-transcribed
strand to the transcribed strand in the
tumor, there are more mutations in the
non-transcribed strand. When we move to
the XPC tumors from the Guatemalan
patients, we find no removal on mutagenic
lesions right across the genome
irrespective of transcription level, but
in the transcribed strand, very efficient
removal.
Now these are striking illustrations of
the fact that it depends critically which
strand of the DNA is damaged, which one
gets repaired. If the cells fail to repair
the non-transcribed strand, mutation rate
is very high when replication comes along
there. On the other strand, the
transcribed strand, it doesn't matter how
well that's repaired in the Guatemalan
population. Because they can't repair the
other strand, cancer is high. So that the
repair of these transcribed strand could
be very efficient, but if confers
absolutely no protection against
UV-induced mutations and carcinogenesis.
Now, if we can turn to another response of
the skin to ultraviolet exposure, sunburn.
We often think and it's established more
or less that the risk for melanoma from
the sun is related to how many sunburns
you get. Well in squamous carcinoma
there's a very different situation. This
is the spectrum of xeroderma pigmentosum
patients from sun exposure, you can have a
patient with very high erythema and
sunburn. You can have patients with
freckling. Patients that develop severe
skin cancer. So you're going to have this
range, and this is under genetic control.
If you look, and this is data published
recently from England where they
have...bring in all the XPC patients from
the country, and treat them and follow
them in one single location. And this was
reported a couple of years ago. If you
look at sunburn versus which gene in the
XP repair pathway is mutated. If you look
at the patients with mutations in XPC,
XPE, or XPV which are genes that code for
proteins involved in the processing of DNA
damage in the non-expressed regions of the
genome.
They get cancer but they get no sunburn.
However, if the genes are involved in
repair and in transcription, sunburn is
very high. If you now look at the
probability of cancer, and then look at
patients that are involved...in which the
genes involved in transcription, cancer
appears slowly over time. And the 50%
onset is out...almost out as late as the
normal population. If we look at XPC and E
patients which are involved in the repair
of the non-transcribed regions and they
don't get sunburn, the cancers are
appearing more rapidly. Their 50% onset is
about the age of 20. So an acute sunburn
in this disease is actually delays
squamous carcinoma. It's the converse of
what you get with melanoma. As an aside,
it's interesting for me to note that the
50% onset here is in the early 20s. In
American xeroderma patients, it occurs
below the age of 10 which is reminiscent
for my childhood that England is a pretty
cloudy, damn rainy place. So let me just
summarize. Xeroderma pigmentosum and
related nucleotide repair diseases
highlight mechanisms of sunburn and
cancer. Repair is more rapid in more
highly expressed genes. Presumably because
an expressed gene has to open up the
chromatin to allow transcription to work
whereupon repair can work. Now deficient
repair of solar UV products in the
non-transcribed strands, and in
unexpressed DNA results in a high mutation
rate and cancer, but deficient repair in
the transcribed strand results in
increased sunburn.
Cancer is delayed or not increased. And in
fact, in Cockayne Syndrome, which is
uniquely involved in the repair of the
transcribed strands, those patients with
Cockayne Syndrome have severe
developmental disorders, but as far as we
know they never get cancer. So, my
question that I leave you with is, "Can we
increase repair in otherwise healthy
persons to protect against skin cancer
including melanoma and other cancers?" And
alternatively, since the nucleotide
excision repair pathway repairs UV-type
damage which is large modifications of DNA
very similar to what occurs when you use
chemotherapy like cisplatins. Since it's
the same repair pathway, "Can we inhibit
repair, and then sensitize cancers to
chemotherapy with very few side effects?"
So I leave you with that. Thank you.
♪ [music] ♪